but I'm wondering you said that um there
was financing already attached mm-hmm
where did that financing come from it's
you know the angel investor okay and
coincidentally her name is Anjali okay
all right so she burning yeah she she
sourced the financing a hundred percent
by herself so did you entertain at some
point attaching sponsorship or going out
to try to get sponsorship for it yeah
absolutely i mean that's the that's the
dream of everyone and we you know we
have a relationship with a sponsor on it
although they're more of marketing and
and sort of publicity help right now um
i think that you know obviously then
that's one of the cool things about
working with online projects is because
they end up breaking off you know if you
do get a sponsor they they end up
breaking off pieces of your project and
then spreading it everywhere you know
they'll use it on their side it'll be
found under a different article just
because the subject matter fans of that
product will then start looking at your
project you know the problem is and
that's what's going on right now is that
madison avenue you know your traditional
companies haven't quite figured out how
to use the internet and to use that
marketing you know there was a time you
know a couple years ago where YouTube
seated a bunch of money and they they
created all these projects and a lot of
money flowed in but people didn't really
know how to quantify the results or like
did it work did we get you know fans
based on sponsoring and lately I've
found because I also do to other web
series that are that are very successful
at they that the targeted audience like
if you get somebody who likes say a teen
pop band and you end up working with
them that teen pop band can guarantee to
deliver you know teenagers a certain age
men women or girls or boys and
and the the companies can then say look
if we're if we have a weak point in you
know girls 12 to 18 then we know if we
work with this one band and do it do a
series with them that will reach those
girls and so now it's becoming more of a
targeted marketing strategy where a
sponsor will be able to come on and say
I you know I'm looking to shore up my
you know boys 25 to 35 you know where
can I go and they can turn to a show
like video game high school which is
it's an incredibly successful show with
you know that age range or if you look
at somebody like pewdiepie that runs you
know his his video game you know vlog or
episodes if you're a video game company
you're going to want to go for him
because video game consumers are are on
that and one of the cool things about
città dopes is you know when Brian and
been you know decided to shift the focus
and make it a lot about the
pharmaceutical sale of marijuana a light
bulb went off in my head and I said well
talk about a targeting marketed
marketing strategy if we can hook our
wagon to what's going on in Colorado
what's going on in Washington State and
Oregon there's no one marketing that
right now so the idea that we could work
hand in hand with either a
pharmaceutical company or with a chain
of grow factories or even with a
paraphernalia or paper company there's a
lot out there I feel like there's a it's
it's a market that's sitting there that
they're not doing any marketing right
now I don't know if they can do an ad on
television I don't know if they can run
an ad in a newspaper but they can
sponsor our show and and get the word
out so we're kind of offering a solution
to a marketing problem is is the way to
look at it from the producer standpoint
you